amoureuse bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france alors
tout d'abord comment a été perçu cette
prise de repos obligatoire par les
salariés ou son entreprise puisque ce
fut le cas pour les salariés d'alstom
oui effectivement chez chez alstom donc
il vient un accord entre entre les
organisations syndicales et la direction
donc à porter sur la prise de 11 jours
de congé ce qui au passage est mieux que
ce qui s'est fait dans le reste de la
métallurgie ou d'accords de la
métallurgie parle de 15 jours alors pour
les salariés disons que dans un sens ça
a été ça c'est ça s'est relativement
bien passée même si ça a été compliqué
certes ça a été des congés forcés alors
ceci dit ça se place effectivement dans
un cadre de deux ou les moules et les
sites ont été mis à l'arrêt alors c'est
pas l'entreprise qui les a mis à l'arrêt
nas et les salariés qui ont arrêté de
travailler et qui donc soit se sont mis
en arrêt de travail ou en bref parce que
pour alstom il fallait juste que les
usines continuent de tourner mais donc
on les quinze jours les 11 jours de de
reproposer on dans un sens permis aux
salariées bas 2-2 d'être protégé du
coronavirus et en n'allant pas en
n'allant pas au travail pour bon pour
l'entreprise effectivement c'est
clairement à un gain de temps de travail
puisque c'est pendant ces jours là elle
a pu économiser l'argent équivalent au
salaire des congés donc elle a pu à sa
paire mais que ses jours de congés soit
pas utilisée par la suite c'est une
servante ou un grand gain pour
l'entreprise qui aura eu des salariés
disponible plus tôt alors qu'on est il
également de du chômage partiel on sait
que certaines entreprises comme psa ou
safran ont pensé justement la perte de
salaire ont créé des fonds solidarité
qui sont en partie financés par un
système de dons
deux jours de congé de leurs employés
alors effectivement il ya des
entreprises où il ya eu çà eux
pour notre part on n'est pas du tout
favorable et d'ailleurs va chez alstom
sanaa ça n'a pas du tout été mis en
place un système de dons voilà on est
dans un cadre où effectivement
l'entreprise a utilisé l'activité
partielle
le nouveau nom du chômage partiel donc à
utiliser l'activité partielle tout
d'abord auprès des salariés ouvriers
production et les techniciens de
production donc là où l'entreprise n'a
pas pu relancer la bavure relancer tout
de suite parce que les salariés
refusaient de prendre le travail et donc
ça a pu être jusqu'à deux semaines trois
semaines par contiennent des salariés où
il ya des sites ou à la production s'est
arrêtée seulement quelques jours donc
l'activité partielle a été très peu
utilisé et dans une seconde phase donc
maintenant que que alstom a fait
reprendre de manière assez assez imposé
disons c'est pas du volontariat donc à
fait reprendre de manière assez imposé
dans toutes les sites de production donc
depuis depuis même quatre semaines à ses
principes de production qui ont repris
depuis quatre cinq semaines donc
maintenant tous les sites de production
ont repris la direction utilise
l'activité partielle aux crêpes des
salariés qui sont en télétravail
donc on avait à peu près la moitié des
salariés en télétravail c'est donc tous
les gens de bureau les cadres les
ingénieurs
beaucoup de cadres les ingénieurs les
personnels d'études qui eu d'enquêté en
télétravail et donc maintenant la
direction utilise le télétravail auprès
de ses personnels là en organisant donc
des semaines partielle de travail donc
elle a eu elle est là elle a clairement
utilisé utiliser l'activité partielle
d'abord sur les ouvriers production pour
les personnels de production pour pour
réussir à pour profiter en fait de
l'aubaine et donc ne pas
couvrir cette période d'absence de
travail puis maintenant elles
l'utilisent vers l'est vers les
personnels qui sont aidées travail
justement concernant le télétravail on
parle parfois davantage mais on sait que
cette période de pandémie a obligé
environ cinq millions de salariés à
travailler de chez eux dans des
conditions parfois peu propice à la
concentration est ce que finalement ce
télétravail n'a pas mis en lumière les
failles du système
oui - oui oui moi je pense clairement et
c'est enfin c'est ce qu'on pense aussi
dans mon syndicat le télétravail c'est
quelque chose qui est poussé depuis des
années par les entreprises alors
effectivement d'un côté ça peut avoir un
côté de flexibilité un intéressant pour
le salarié mais ça montre lorsqu'il est
utilisé de manière importante ça montre
les limites de la chose d'un côté on n'a
pas forcément toujours de bonnes
conditions de travail de certains
salariés ne disait pas c'est difficile
de travailler avec les enfants en même
temps bien évidemment et ça a été une
difficulté
le second problème et ça ça me met sa
montre en fait tous les problèmes que
nous avons dans l'activité depuis 10 20
ans avec tout le nouveau système de
management
les nouveaux les plateaux les
plateformes là comme vous montrer à
l'écran
tous ces grands plateaux qui sont des
lieux des mauvais lieu de travail alors
il y a effectivement quelques avantages
des fois être en plateau mais bien
souvent ça présente d'autres
inconvénients notamment pour les
salariés qui sont qui sont dans dumas
qui ont des risques psychosociaux
importants sens qu on appelle ça comme
ça les risques psycho sociaux
c'est-à-dire du stress au travail du
bruit au travail est en fait le
télétravailleur d'un côté a donné une
petite soupapes aux salariés en n'étant
pas des fois certains salariés disent
qu'ils ont une meilleure productivité en
étant chez eux en télétravail donc ça ça
montre bien que ça veut dire qu'il ya un
souci dans le travail dans le fait de
travailler
à l'entreprise qui a des problèmes
d'organisation important et de l'autre
côté donc ça c'est le second effet mais
le télétravail a aussi montré que
certains salariés travaillent dix sept
heures 8h 9h 10h 11h 12h par jour que
des fois le chef les appels à 8 heures
des fois le chef les appels à 20h pour
re surveiller qu'ils ont bien fait une
journée complète alors une journée qui
commence à 8h et qui finit à 20h ça fait
ça fait beaucoup
en france on al cette merveilleuse chose
qu'ils savent pas merveilleuse c'est
ironique qui s'appelle le forfait jour
donc qui permet de dire à nombre de
salariés qui n'ont pas temps de travail
dans la journée et ça c'est des
problèmes et les entreprises on profite
beaucoup avec le télétravail de cette
pression et de cette permanence du
travail qu'ils peuvent mettre aux
salariés et donc alors on a noté dans
certaines entreprises
une montée du stress au travail d'aider
certaines certains risques psychosociaux
qui remonte sur les salariés
très bien merci beaucoup boris
amoureuses avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes délégué cgt
alstom